and when you think about that hyper
printing is it simply the game of
devalue the currency to pay off the debt
in the future with those devalued
currencies and so we can make a logical
argument why we should do it but
do they not understand what the impact
is or do they not have another choice so
they do understand it but they have no
other options they have to do it anyways
not to get overly political but
you know you do have a situation where
the people who benefit most from the
money printing the contillionaires a
term that we coined on the kaiser report
who get the money first and buy assets
and who make out like bandits
they're not uh unhappy with the money
that's being printed
uh simultaneously it would appear as
though there is a trend toward
reducing people's rights rights of
movement
right of communication
free speech
even in some places in europe for
example people are getting locked up
i don't think you can separate those two
i think this trend toward hyper printing
and locking people up it go together uh
because they don't want to blow back
they don't want to end up
like another reign of terror situation
where 35 000 french noblemen got
beheaded by the peasants who got tired
of all the money printing in the
monarchy right so they're they're aware
of this they're like wait a minute we
don't want to do that so let's just lock
people up and print all the money anyway
so they're they're out of control
basically i mean i don't think that's
that's that's a wild statement uh you
know i think that would be historically
we've seen this before and economically
we see this happening now and we also
there's nobody in may who's in a
position to write policy that's making
any intelligent comments or choices
about this at all i haven't heard a
single person make any intelligent
comments about what really would need to
be done
so when we think about the current
situation we've got six plus percent cpi
inflation we've got
four to four and a half percent
unemployment there's 11 million open
jobs in america um there are 80 percent
of americans that are already being paid
over 15 an hour
and
we've got this public health crisis
which continues to fluctuate in terms of
i think the uh the uh
uh severity of the
public health crisis and which
areas in the country are or are not
worried about it uh which seems to be
bleeding into monetary fiscal policy how
do both of you think about
the current environment they're now
talking about tapering they're saying
that oh look we're going to actually
change this stacey you're smirking so
what do you think is actually going to
happen here do you think that they can
taper at all they've been saying that
for
five years six years that we've been
covering this on kaiser report and every
single time the headlines come out that
they're about to taper we always tell
people on kai's report they're not going
to taper because you can't taper a ponzi
so we've said that for the last six
years uh they'll continue to say it and
it seems to work at least uh temporarily
you know to the markets respond the
dollar soars everybody thinks oh
they're gonna taper for real this time
but they're never going to and um
how how can they how can they right like
we
there's more debt than ever so
they can never taper that ponzi scheme
when you think about interest rates are
we going to see
nominal negative interest rates in
america
um
i think
we probably already have them right we
already have negative real rights yeah
we already have negative real nominal
but do you think we'll see the actual
negative
rates like you'll literally go and
they'll say the negative rate is you
know negative one percent uh
when they are ready to just give up
because if if they do that then the
dollars toast
yeah we had a little say so that during
the 2000 or any crisis remember there
was this talk about we can't break the
buck
the money market funds out there which
are not they're not cash right there's
it's uh short-term debt all money market
funds and there was a threat that they
would
go under a dollar the official rate and
they did everything that was humanly
possible including remember you had tim
geithner and others go in front of
congress and say we need
you know just under a trillion dollars
uh congress said we need to read what
the document is and they said okay look
at it tomorrow market crashed that night
and then they came back and they they
signed it and um that led to
just 16 17 trillion and various bailouts
and credit facilities so so i think that
rather than go negative nominal on the
actual rate i mean that just keep going
extraordinary printing i think actually
i i realized you could see it in the
the news basically the the geopolitics
over the past few months is like there
seems to be some sort of tension really
building escalating rapidly with china
they'll do nominal rates and they'll
blame china they'll say we had to do it
because of china and they own all this
debt of ours and they own
you know so much of our
bonds and stuff like that so they'll say
they had to do this because of china and
china forced their hand you know the the
fact that uh all these chinese companies
are gonna have to de-list from
uh the new york stock exchange and stuff
like that i just think there's like some
sort of building you know the thucydides
trap is real and it's happening and this
is this is the moment they're going to
use that as an opportunity to say we
need nominal rates and if you're a
patriot you'll support this because this
has to be done